you're gonna have to do everyone thanks
so much for coming today as you know the
second of a series of three castle
lectures the castle lectures are the
signature lecture series for the
undergraduate ethics politics and
economics major at Yale they are made
possible by a very generous generous
support from John Castle in honor of his
ancestor James Pierpoint
who was one of the founders of Yale and
we're very pleased that John Castle
takes an interest in this lecture series
and is here today and of this lecture
series is to help us think about ethics
in a systematic and scholarly way how
epics is intertwined with some of the
most important political and economic
questions of our day and one person who
has been working in this area for did
you say 37 years on that was a maybe
that's that's from a childhood is
Katherine's psychic she is the Ryan
family professor of human rights policy
at the Harvard Kennedy School and she's
the author of many books on this subject
including most most recently I think
it's hot off the press or not even off
the press now it's off the press okay
it's off the press you can find this now
in your closest bookstore evidence for
hope making human rights work for the
20th century 21st through 21st
[Laughter]
and something else you should know is
that this lecture series culminates in a
book that will come out with Yale
University Press in another year or so
right Kevin so stay tuned for that as
well but you're you're here at creation
and what Kathryn helped us think about
yesterday was how to think about not
just rights but also responsibilities
not just human rights but how are we
responsible for human rights and today I
think she's going to come back to that
topic a little bit before talking about
a very particular kind of right voting
rights and what are our responsibilities
these are the voting rights so Kathryn
so glad you're here and we're looking
forward to hearing what you have to say
Greg thank you so much Francis and thank
you mr. castle
it is a great honor actually to be here
to deliver the castle lectures and even
more of an honor to have you in the
audience so thank you and to have other
distinguished friends and colleagues in
the audience as well so thank you for
coming yesterday I spoke of the history
of Rights and duties and I made an
argument that basically from its birth
Human Rights had gotten separated from
explicit statement about individual
responsibilities and duties and I argued
that we needed to somehow rediscover or
recover the role of individual
responsibilities in our human rights
scholarship in our human rights activism
and human rights work but I made it very
clear I wasn't interested in in legal
responsibility that I want to reopen
human rights treaties up again and
somehow insert legal responsibilities
I'm talking about
ethical responsibilities I'm talking
about political responsibilities and so
and yesterday I talked about
cosmopolitan dues we have by way of our
social connection to global problems
including
i'ma change I had my international
relations hat on today I'm going to
speak also as a scholar of democracy and
human rights to address civic duties in
democracies and especially the civic
responsibility to vote now as in
international relations scholars I work
mainly on norms on transnational
advocacy networks and on the power of an
effectiveness of human rights and you so
you may wonder what am i doing talking a
topic of today about the civic duty to
vote or tomorrow about free speech and
the right to protest but I'm mainly
interested in my mean my work has really
been devoted over the long term to
understand the way social change occurs
globally and in the United States over
long periods of time and the role of
changes in norms and beliefs in that in
those processes of change so in my
previous books for example activists
Beyond Borders that I wrote with
Margaret Keck or the justice cascade
that looked at human rights prosecutions
I traced the history sometimes the deep
history of important norms and campaigns
that have reshaped our world so as I
approach rights and responsibilities
including the responsibility to vote I
do so as a scholar of norms and ideas
okay I'm not a lawyer right and I'm not
talking about making legal changes and
I'm not a philosopher and I'm not
talking about how we can a theorized
obligation or duty in a non ideal world
okay I'm I'm going to talk about the
practical politics of norm construction
and the nine ideal world and the
importance of norms about responsibility
for voting and for participation and
then to tomorrow about free speech and
protest now I'll argue that we do not
yet have strong and well in turn
internalized norms in this country about
the responsibility for voting since 40
percent of eligible voters don't vote
but it's possible to think about how to
build norms for the civic responsibility
of vote
and in this sense I'm talking
responsibly at two levels responsibility
for some norm entrepreneurs to work on
constructing a norm up which constantly
about the responsibility of individuals
to vote okay so this sort of this double
layer of response of thinking about
responsibility now
I've learned a thing or two about
processes of norm construction and
enforcement in my previous research so
first in international relations we
define norms as standards of appropriate
behavior for actors with a given
identity so we talk about norm change we
mean how do we change our standards
about what's the appropriate behavior
and I've studied historical norm
campaigns starting with the anti-slavery
campaign campaigns about woman suffrage
and some quirky historical campaigns
that actually learned a lot from like
the history of the abolition of foot
binding in China or early campaigns
against female genital cutting in Africa
and then I've also looked a course at
more modern campaigns in the sense of
the emergence of human rights norms in
the 20th century and then some of the
more specific campaigns around specific
norms including campaigns for individual
criminal accountability for mass
atrocity now each of the campaign's I
studied began with powerful agency of
individuals and groups who struggled in
the face of what would peer to be
insurmountable structural odds okay and
so people often say oh you keep talk
about an agency but you keep ignoring
the structural odds and that's a bias I
have because of the kind of change I'm
interested in studying and because all
of my research over decades now every
time I look at a new norm that I and I
want to say where did that come from and
I start tracing it back I always find a
story of individuals and of agency and
of groups who organize and people think
very often that they are certifiably
insane when they start working or and
in some cases and that's the issue in
some cases they're able to bring these
campaigns to be very very successful
agents of of change so much so that they
convert what is kind of the craziness of
the initial demand into the
taken-for-granted notion of a norm
because a well internalized norm
once you've you know I've looked at
something that I call the norm life
cycle right you've norms emerge at a
certain stage but if if these early norm
entrepreneurs succeed they get to a
point where you have a process of norm
internalization and what happens with a
norm is it begins to be taken for
granted and instead of norm
entrepreneurs you really have processes
of conformity that start to work it's
the thing to do and people begin to
conform to that norm and if you have a
really well internalized norm at the end
you have something that is so taken for
granted we don't mean discuss it you
know so for example we don't discuss
today whether except in Saudi Arabia
whether women should vote or not right
and in fact if someone tries to discuss
it they will receive social sanctions
because that's what happens when you
have norm violation as you get social
sanctions that's not a topic that we
talk about okay now so the norm
entrepreneurs so there's these two I
made this there's multiple things I
think it's a two stage of stage of
normal printers who are very principled
people and and usually if sex successful
strategic as well okay so sometimes you
think oh these are just kind of the
pie-in-the-sky of principle people but
the ones who really succeed tend to be
both simultaneously principled and
strategic about how to move their norm
campaign ahead
but the
so so for that reason I'm very
interested in agency now my colleagues
have over the years sometimes reminded
me that that I'm ignoring structural
factors and I still remember when I just
started working on anti-slavery and a
colleague came out and she said well of
course you know slavery was ended
because was no longer profitable okay so
I dug into the literature and what I
discovered was to the Contras an immense
literature on the end of slavery but
Robert Fogel who's one of the people
whose who's really written a pretty
definitive work on it says to the
contrary slavery was ended at the height
of its profitability by people flame
with moral fervor and so so that you
know I continue to think I continue to
place a lot of importance on agency in
terms of initiating norm campaigns but
eventually we're going to have to talk
eventually you have to talk about how do
you move to a process of Norman ternal
ization and and get to process
conformity okay so now so there's the
second reason why I'm interested in norm
change an agency and it's partly just
when you reach a certain point of your
life and when you're a senior scholar
all of a sudden you can just personally
your witness a very dramatic norm in
your lifetime right and so I always
point out that you know when I went when
I first started studying political
science it you know there were no women
in my department at Columbia University
it wasn't you know really clear if I
could get a job as a tenured political
science in a scientist in a research
university much less at Harvard and I
see Francis not because we were in
graduate school at the same time and and
that was an issue you know but there
were a whole series of of other issues
some of them would seem kind of
superficial but you know that my
children did they don't believe that
that everyone smoked
everywhere all the time including
enclosed spaces with children that
nobody's parents buckled their children
into seatbelts indeed there were not
feet belts in the backseat and we all
crawled over the to hang out in the back
with the dog in that the notion of
recycling didn't exist and so in our
lifetime we've also seen these major and
other may seem superficial but important
changes in norms since and we can study
we have some idea of how those things
happened right like I have an argument
about smoking which is that you know
smoking started to really change when
research on passive smoke came around
right so as long as you were just doing
the loans you're doing stupid things
your own body you couldn't get norm
change as soon as it was you were doing
stupid things to somebody else's body
you started to see real movement on
norms and this is something that Harold
Koh and his brother Howard Koh have
really been working on nowadays about
trying to take the revolution we've had
on norms on smoking in this country and
elsewhere and see if n really be
transported to other parts of the world
where that norm revolution is yet to
happen so but I don't have just a rosy
view of norm shift because there have
been other issues where I've seen a lot
of backlash rollback and backlash for
example I've worked a lot on the issue
of torture and in this country as you
know we've seen a movement back on what
we thought was a well institutionalized
norm against torture and instead we find
that that it is not well into stars
previously whatever was going on state
officials would not stand up and defend
torture publicly and nowadays that is
something commonplace but more
importantly I want to talk about the the
mark that my research and my lived time
in Latin America has had on my views
about norms about beliefs and about
democracy and voting okay because really
the experience that most shaped me in
terms of my thinking about democracy and
voting was really living in and working
in and researching Latin America at a
time when the entire region was under
very there
authoritarian regimes so for those of
you here yesterday remember I talked
about Latin Americans in 1948 making
these amazing contributions to human
rights through the American Declaration
of Rights and duties of man but the next
stage is that by 1950s virtually all the
countries of the region were turning
into quite a Thorat Aryan regimes and it
it's in it's good to be at Yale to talk
about this because I learned a lot from
some of the democracy scholars who
worked here at Yale compared rongzi
scholars people like juan linz el stefan
and of course Dahl
but so so I still recall when I was
getting ready to go down to UM as a as a
college student down to Uruguay in 1976
where the New York Times called it the
torture chamber of the Americas and
because more a larger percentage of the
population of Uruguay was in prison than
in any other country the world okay and
I remember thinking what is happening
how is it possible that Uruguay that had
been democratic virtually through the
entire 20th century so we're not talking
about a banana republic here we're
talking in a country that hadn't had a
long democratic tradition that had a
welfare state that had high education
levels that had good income levels and
never less suffered this brutal coup in
73 and was had become the torture
chamber the America so think what went
wrong in Uruguay and that was a puzzle
that people like juan linz l7 and others
were trying to answer and ultimately one
of the most important conclusions that
these democracy scholars reached and
after decades of research on the rise
and fall of democracy is that norms and
beliefs about legitimacy of democracy
mattered and one man started very early
on this topic because he he insisted the
importance of of of legitimacy as a
important factor here and so for he
reminded us that the legitimacy
democracy was essential for its it
continuity and for lens insertion was
not illegitimate just because we can
imagine a preferable ideal okay
it was illegitimate if it was
illegitimate if kin with legitimate
compared to other institutions that
could in reality be established so Lin's
argued that intellectuals intellectuals
play a major role in formatting
elaborating and transmitting ideas about
legitimacy in Latin America at the time
both the left and the right including
intellectuals and social movements
contributed to the D legitimation of
democracy and the work of Lintz and
Stepan has been carried on by the way I
want to say since I'm talking about
l-step and some of you may know l seven
died last week and i just want to
remember his contributions the first
time I came to Yale with a conference on
the authoritarianism in Argentina and
Uruguay I was a I was not even in
graduate school yet I was working a
human rights organization and it's just
a tribute to who L 7 was as a scholar
that he you know conovan would invite
kind of a stray human rights person and
not treat them as a second-class citizen
in his conference on on Uruguayan
Argentina but people took up lenses work
and Stefan's work and particularly Scot
me and wearing a colleague of mine at
Harvard Kennedy School is now done what
I consider the definitive work on the
rise and fall of democracy in Latin
America and his main explanation okay
there are two main explanations and
either there I can't go into that but
they are very carefully operationalized
and measured okay the main isolation is
the belief in democracy that key
political actors have in the country and
he did that by measuring political party
statements and all sorts of statements
of various actors about democracy and
the second factor is the inner the
atmosphere the international atmosphere
within which a countries are operating
and so the issue then becomes if
democracy failed in Latin America in
part because people stopped believing in
it why did people thought believe in
democracy and what made them start
believing again
people stop believing democracy because
the real world democracy in the region
fell so fall short of their ideals okay
the left dreamed of a more participatory
egalitarian democracy and they disdained
the pale substitute that they called
bourgeois democracy meanwhile the US
government and the right in Latin
America also stop blaming democracy
which they saw at the dangerous context
for the spread of communism and the u.s.
worked to overthrow leftist leaders in
the region including some that had
democratically elected and so in this
sense the you know we had the u.s.
failure to tolerate democratically
elected governments led to a spiral
basically where the Left decided that
you couldn't come to elect you couldn't
come to power through elections because
you'd be overthrown and so the left
decides that they have to turn to armed
struggle as a way to promote the ideal
form of democracy that they believe
never has existed and so the
confrontation of armed revolutionaries
and anti communist authoritarian
produced a body count of dead and
disappeared in Latin America in the
1970s and 80s that had not been seen in
most countries since the colonial period
so when I speak of a responsibility to
vote it is just one of a whole series of
civic responses and practices by which
we affirm we affirm our belief in
support of democracy and that when we
think about legitimacy of our political
system we need to compare our evaluation
democracy to other actually existing
political systems and not just to one
eyes one's ideals and it and you know I
know that this is a you know
an old citation and people are tired of
hearing it but I got the exact Churchill
citation at least the exact citation we
hear it sometimes and it is this quote
no one pretends that democracy is
perfect or all wise indeed it has been
said so Churchill is citing somebody
else here but we don't know who it has
been said that democracy is the worst
form of government except for all those
other forms that have been tried from
time to time so I also found though a
new appreciative devoxx
human-rights watching my colleagues in
Latin America as they rediscover
democracy and as they rediscovered human
rights as a crucial part of democracy
and so human rights organizations began
to embrace it reevaluate remarks me
embrace human rights as my Argentine
colleague Elizabeth Helene described in
Argentina quote human rights became the
key element of a proposal for
construction of a more humanist tolerant
and pluralist democratic culture for
many activists human rights protections
in the value of M value democracy became
a genuine conviction not just a useful
slogan and during this period the Latin
American Left moved away from revolution
and towards more reformist solutions the
stability of democracy in the region
today and there are some exceptions like
Venezuela of course but in most of the
regions stability democracy is I think
large the result of stronger normative
preferences for democracy partly born of
this experience of harsh
authoritarianism okay so this leads me
back to the topic for today when I see
the kinds of arguments for violence that
are being made by some of the anti-shah
right this which is short for militant
anti-fascists I don't see anything new
or revolutionary I see something all too
familiar and I believe dangerous and
when I see social movements at both the
right and the left in this country
contributing to such extensive dealer
donation of the state that it has become
an act of political symbolism not to
vote it appears to me similar to the way
that Latin America stopped believing in
democracy thus contributing to its fall
so in August 2017 a national survey of
thousand seven hundred current
undergraduate students in u.s. four-year
colleges found that 19 percent of
students agree this acceptable for
student groups to use violence to
prevent a speaker from making offensive
and hurtful statements this is really
quite a high percentage if you believe
as I do that such violence is not only
ethically unacceptable but also
ineffective in persuading broader
publics to align themselves with the
goals of the movement how did we reach a
point in our society where 19 percent
undergraduate think violence is
acceptable to stop speech
and a new paper called him at the
Kennedy School has argued that at least
some parts of three very distinct social
movements Occupy Wall Street Tea Party
and black lives matter
some parts unless I know some parties
movements contributed to reinforcing the
broad idea the illegitimate II of the
state an idea that was central to the
2016 presidential election
okay so Trump came to power based on a
story of the illegitimate II of the
state this story paradoxically was
shared and shaped by movements at the
left so first let me clarify and as I
explained yesterday when I talk about
real about responsibility I'm not
talking about legal liability I'm not
talking about blame or causality okay so
when I'm not gonna go back and say who
is to blame for anything there's a
difference between you have a
responsibility and you are responsible
the second appears to suggest causality
or blame where the first is an ethical
and political statement I will be
arguing that we have responsibilities
not about who is responsible okay
instead I'm using what iris Marianne
Jung called a social connection model of
responsibility and what my co-author fed
an underbelly under the via and I have
called networked responsibility the idea
that all people connected to a
structural injustice or other human
rights problem and who are in a position
to act have an ethical responsibility to
take action now and that would include
an ethical responsibility I'm arguing to
take action around issues of voting now
in speaking of rights and individual
responsibilities especially around
voting we we we revive a debate in the
social sciences about structure and
agency so there's a long-standing belief
that stressing individual responsible
agency in the face of the much greater
impact of systemic and structural
factors is naive at best
perhaps pernicious at worst so some
people think that too much tension
individual responsibility may distract
or diminish our attention from the real
or structural cause of them injustice
and from the responsibility of the state
our political parties our economic
system etc for
big event but I'm a political scientist
I totally understand the arguments I
know about the way that the our
presidential system with single-member
districts and a winner-take-all voter
system leads to two parties struggling
to attract swing votes at the center
such two-part system is less likely to
make you know to reach out to the broad
range of voters in this country and
really make arguments that motivate
those people to vote so you know when I
talk about this and including when I
talk with my son about this you know my
sons they say the Democratic Party you
did nothing to mobilize the youth the
problem is a Democratic Party right they
voted of course I'm gonna say they
didn't vote but there was a sense that
you know the system is to blame the
parties are to blame the candidate is to
blame everyone's to blame not people who
who and basically they give their
friends and a pass who didn't vote you
know so I could go on about you know the
problem with with certain kinds of money
in our system the problem the electoral
college you've heard it all right the
problem that we don't have a vacation
day for our elections the problem with
their voter registration system the you
know we know about voter suppression I'm
not trying to minimize any of this I'm
simply trying to say that that
responsibility individual consulate is
still crucial for voting exactly because
an individual decision to vote is
according to many political scientists
and economists irrational it's
irrational for they say for any
individual to go and vote because our
vote will not count for anything so it
needs it needs to be motivated by
something other than self interest in
rationality it needs be motivated by a
belief I think in civic responsibility
and in fact economic theorists of voting
are usually expressed surprise that the
voting rates are so high so we look at
60% which was the turnout in the last
election to end the 2016 election 60% of
eligible voters voted and we say that's
real
but if your economic there's a democracy
and you think vote is irrational you go
what are all those people doing voting
when they know that their vote won't
make any difference now on the
irrational vote and I want to tell you
about some political science friends of
mine a married couple to illustrate what
I mean my friends went to vote in the
primary of the Democratic Party he was
going to vote for Bernie she was gonna
vote for Hillary so they could have
stayed home because they were gonna
cancel one another out but they believed
in civic responsibility to vote so they
persisted they went to the polls they
were told they couldn't vote because the
records show they had voted in the
Republican primary in the previous
election well they certainly didn't vote
in the Republican primary this friend
was one of the people who first
explained to me what it meant to be a
Blue Dog Republican I didn't know that
term and she explained to me she said
that means you would vote for a blue dog
as long as he was a Democrat and so they
protested forcefully and they were
promised that the voting station would
look into it and they should come back
later in the afternoon inquire when they
returned later from you and they
discovered that their persistence in
their irrational decision to vote had
helped their local voting board discover
a major malfunction in their software a
malfunction that had disenfranchised
hundreds of voters okay so in this case
the personal agency motivated by sense
of responsibility was actually necessary
to help find and address a systemic
problem in their voting system so I take
this and I take this I believe from Hana
Arendt but I have an event scholar in
the audience social tell me that even in
situations where structures are powerful
and determine outcomes personal action
is possible necessary and cannot be
practically useless at least in the
long-term this poses issues of personal
responsibility for all of us and Arendt
argues we cannot retreat from that
responsibility by stressing what we know
about theories of caught a structural
causality near the end of a rents book
Eichmann and Jerusalem she refers
directly to the theories that may serve
as reasons to dismiss personal
responsibility
she writes I quote another such escape
from the area of ascertainable facts and
personal
sponsibility are the countless theories
based on nonspecific abstract
hypothetical assumption from the Zeit
gas down to the Oedipus complex which
are also general they explain and
justify every event in every deed no
alternative to what actually happened is
even considered and no person could have
acted differently from the way he did
act all these cliches have in common
that they make judgment superfluous and
out of them is devoid of all risk so I
actually am less harsh about theory than
she would be I don't dismiss there I
think we have to constantly take
everything we know about about theory to
actually inform our activism right
because we're going to be more strategic
in getting people to vote if we
understand exactly what are the forces
and the structures that are suppressing
voting but I am but I believe as I think
Aaron has said there that we must be
cautious not like theory justify action
or inaction or imply that no alternative
to what actually happened is possible we
still have to make judgments about what
is right and wrong as well as what works
and doesn't work citizens are most fully
realized through their work together so
I don't want to say by talking
individual judgment and here again
following a rant we have to realize that
citizens are most fully realized in
their work together in the public sphere
and that work includes both the work of
defending rights our own and those of
others and an exercising responsibility
now in this country we talk a lot about
the right to vote we believe we have a
right to vote and we have a right not to
vote but we don't speak very much about
the civic duty to vote or a civic
responsibility vote the concept of a
duty to vote is even denigrated by some
and as you'll gather I believe strongly
we have a civic duty to vote and it's a
response to the many rights and
privileges that we have as citizens it
is not a very big expectation that given
the rights and privileges citizenship
that we might exercise the duties of
citizenship voting for most among them
of course we want that our participation
in our political life to go way beyond
just voting okay so now I'm certainly
not saying oh of audience enough or
voting is now I'm saying voting is just
a minimal starting point but that is a
necessary piece of what we hope is a
much broader form of participation now
as Irish young argues this
responsibility this as you said social
connections constantly is not primarily
backward-looking as the attribution of
guilt or fault is but rally
forward-looking so our question is we
look forward to voting how can we work
together to transform norms and
practices one short-term forward-looking
issue is the 2018 election for example
while presidential elections get all the
attention in the last midterm election
in 2014
80 % of young eligible voters that's
young means people here aged 18 to 29
stayed home 80 percent stayed home so
the 2018 midterm election is a very
concrete forward-looking issue that we
have on our radar screen now to start
talking about how we can start building
norms about a responsibility to vote I
want to start with my colleagues
professional political scientists just
the other day I had yet another
conversation with yet another
professional political scientist who
doesn't vote and who offers the argument
that voting is irrational this reminded
conversations I've had with two other
political science colleagues over the
years two very different theoretical
orientations about the decision not to
vote one said he believed voting was
irrational he went a step further he
always assigned to his students a text
about the irrational voting in every
class he taught in American politics
usually near the election okay so at
least inadvertently discouraging them
from choosing to vote another colleague
said he thought the structures of
capitalist and the influence of modern
US political system was so powerful that
it was just useless but perhaps
pernicious to vote so how can I respond
to these professors and to the students
who take their classes and the steal
more than justified I'm here political
sign
professor tells you he doesn't vote in
this case I'm using he because they were
all Heath if he doesn't vote then that's
like it's almost like a carte blanche
for you not to vote as well now so one
way to proceed is to start with progress
about what is already happening and in
the last election sixty percent of
eligible was voted that was up 1.2
percent from 2012 that's something many
of us didn't initially understand when
we saw the results of the election
although only 50 percent of youth voted
that's again 18 to 29 there was an
increase in youth voting by 5 points
between 2012 and 2016 so that's a big
increase and if we look at college
voters the numbers are very very
interesting I want to spend some time
with college voters because here we are
at a university first there is a new
there's a new research project on
College voting that's producing some of
the very best data we have on voting the
Institute for democracy in higher
education at Tufts University is
producing the national study of learning
voting and engagement about College
voting is called n souls so I'm gonna
just use that insult okay what I mean
the national study of learning voting
and engagement it involves a survey
almost 10 million college students found
in thousand higher education
institutions in the USA across all 50
states participate institutions give and
fill permission to use their student
enrollment records to be matched to
public voting records yielding precise
data about their students turnouts while
scrupulously protecting the identity of
those individuals ok the demographics of
these nearly 10 million people matched
the demographics of the approximately 20
million college students ok so this data
is actually of higher quality than most
data we have in voting
voter turnout among eligible college
students increase from 2012 2016 by 3
percentage points from 45 point one
percent to forty eight point three
percent which is a positive development
even so that puts college students still
2 points lower than youth voters and 12
points lower than the overall turnout of
eligible voters so there's a lot there's
there's good progress but a long way to
go still now this group of colleges
includes undergraduates
graduates and non-traditional students
so it's not only this is not only the
youth group but the the ensel did it can
break down by age group and another
piece of goods notice that the youngest
group of college students those aged 18
to 21 actually saw a 4% increase in
their voting between 2012 and 2016 and
this is important because we know that
once people start voting and get the
habit of voting they're more likely to
continue voting the future now there's
some fascinating variation here women
vote more than men college students in
the Northeast vote more than those in
the south social science majors vote
more than stem students private
institutions have higher voting rates
but that may be completely due to the
fact that their students are more
affluent and more affluent students are
more likely to vote but there's also
very variation by institution with some
institutions that really have infinitely
higher voting rates so in addition to
the quantitative data ansel staff are
doing qualitative work including focus
groups on campus in depth engaging with
colleges that seek their assistance and
so one thing the ensel data found that
that some institutions saw an increase
as much as 15 percent between 2012 and
2016 so it's really important about it
what are those institutions doing how
can you get an increase in 15% of
student voting even with relatively low
levels in the 40s that's still a massive
jump and they are now exploring about
you know what's the case what is that
there there's still research on the way
but they conclude they say quote we
suspect the campus climates the norms
structures behaviors and attitudes of
people on campus can influence student
decisions whether or not to vote or to
be otherwise politically engaged based
on our research we hypothesize that
pervasive political discussions strong
faculty student relationships couple
with political learning across
disciplines and vibrant electoral
activities are attributes of a robust
campus client for political engagement
know I had dinner last night with some
Yale students think and faculty and I
the Galle students assured me that this
vibrant political this vibrant political
campus climate existed they say exists
here at Yale they were very articulate
about are the kinds of discussions that
are going on the kinds of activities and
I had I had a chance I was so interested
research I had a chance to talk to the
research director Nancy Thomas and she
confirms the importance of underlying
norms and creating a campus climate
leading to high voter turnout and that
faculty students and administrators all
have an important role to play and Nancy
actually said that faculty are critical
to voter turnout and that faculty have
no idea how important they are so when
she they do these these focus groups
with students what they find out is in
these places that are high school social
cohesion and there's high levels of
voting the students are you are saying
things like we love our classes we love
our professors we love our campus and
even though there's differences among
students they're not all unified or
similar in their backgrounds but somehow
that does the atmosphere on campus has
helped to create this climate where
people are more likely to be involved in
to vote and so I you know we know of
course faculty should never ever be
partisan but it's very different to tell
people who you should vote for what
party you should vote for that we never
do and to tell people how you vote and
the you know I have people I have you
know college colleagues who say well you
never you know you don't need to tell
Harvard students how to vote you know
they know how to you don't even tell
tell them and reminds me of the joke my
husband tells which is that you can
always tell a Harvard man but you can't
tell him much but what I've discovered
is Harvard students don't necessarily
know how to vote and oh and just like
students everywhere they're sometimes
afraid to ask to fit to be made to feel
that that you know it's you know they
don't know what they should know and in
fact even my my my Harvard undergraduate
who read a version of this wrote me and
said that that she resonate
with what I was saying about people not
knowing because she has she's very very
capable but she managed to be a vote
absentee in Arizona where she's from
when she went to Brazil she managed to
switch her absentee voting to be able to
vote in Brazil but now she's stymied as
she can't somehow switch back out of
Brazil into a normal absentee voter so
basically there's a positive and a
negative story to tell about voting and
the negative story of course is that
more people vote did not vote then voted
for either the two candidates in the
last election the positive story is
these increases in voting levels
generally among young and among the
college Oh No um now the u.s. system is
not the only way to handle it and I had
a long story to tell you here about
about Latin America with a lot of
there's a lot of mandatory voting and
including in Brazil and I'm gonna cut
most asteroids want to tell you one
piece of it in Brazil does mandatory
voting you have to get a receipt that's
get stamped in order to get government
services and you have to vote but when
you go into the voting machine you have
two buttons that let you protest one
button is I refuse to vote and you push
it and the second button is I vote in
blank okay so which are conceptually
apparently just different issues so if
you refuse to vote you don't even get
counted as having voted and if you open
blank you you do get counted as voting a
blank yeah so what I like about that is
Brazil has made it very clear how deeply
they care about voting if you're gonna
protest well then you have to do as much
work as it would devote you can't feel
self-righteous and be lazy at the same
time by not voting and not only that
Brazilians who I are never I've never
heard of them being you know limited
about alcohol but all alcohol is
prohibited starting on midnight the day
before elections and going all Election
Day until the polls close and of course
it's a holiday so you've got a holiday
in Brazil you've got no nothing to drink
and you've got an obligation to vote and
not surprisingly people do vote now I'm
not advocating I would
advocate mandatory voting this country
would just irritate people so much that
it would would be worse all I'm pointing
out is that some countries take public
policy around voting as seriously as the
United States government takes for
example drug policy they are prepared to
take what we would call draconian
measures to get people to vote
we are not we're prepared to take
draconian measures so do other things
like try to limit drugs okay so it's not
just that they're draconian were not
it's what do we believe is important
enough to take forceful measures about
so skipping over Brazil
I won't tell one more story and then I
want to end
so first the the reason we need norms we
need not just a norm to vote we need the
norm for people to encourage others to
vote okay and this is a tough thing I
have a KY of a colleague Alec Kaiser at
the Kennedy School who is I call a mr.
right to vote he's written an important
book of the history of voting and not by
the United States and I took him out to
lunch and I said I'm going to talk about
voting and I said how do you what do you
think of this possibility vote and he
actually said I have a deep discomfort
with it I've a discomfort with oh he put
it as he admitted he would have to
overcome discomfort in order to actively
check in with others in his life and
encourage them to vote but why
discomfort he said it was perhaps
because many things should be left
political parties and campaigns get the
vote so it's a it's it's a matter of of
parties campaigns and candidates but not
the individuals but we we can't leave it
just of course as a matter of parties
and campaigns
okay we can't leave it just a partisan
campaigns the it's exactly because there
are active measures to have voter
suppression there
active and their orchestrated measures
at voter suppression okay that have made
our system very very difficult for even
smart people like my research assistant
to maneuver as such voters need all the
help they can get
not just from parties not just some
candidates but from their friends their
colleagues their professors their fellow
students and and that that effort needs
to be at least equally active and
orchestrated as some of the efforts of
voter suppression have been now at this
point some of you are thinking that this
is a utopian where we'll never see but
think the active discomfort that other
norm campaigners had to overcome and
that I've read about think about norm
campaigners in a panic and slavery the
vote for women or many of the other
changes that we now take for granted
those norm campaigners you know
obviously it was not a comfortable
discussion to have with your neighbors
about slavery it was not a comfortable
discussion to have about with the men
and your family
about why women need to vote and yet
norm campaigners on all these campaigns
learned how to overcome their their
discomfort in order to make a norm
advocacy just part of one's life
important enough your part is one's life
and what you're asking people to do is
really I mean people in this country
spend way more time
recycling than they do voting for
example and they recycle a lot more and
yet voting is is I think arguably much
more important we spend my students sort
of complain about the time and I I just
say how much time did you spend today
doing some other irrational waste of
time
you know what about video games what
about reading trashy novels what about
watching bad TV shows and you know and I
speak personally from experience and
they all know their heads of course I
just wasted you know time just today
doing something else and yet I can't
spend the hour to go to vote so we know
that peer pressure works
people are very persuaded by people
around them by their peer group to do
what they think is appropriate thing to
do there's a whole body of research in
psychology from Ashton Milgram and many
of
to confirm the importance of peer
pressure on decision-making the you know
obviously we don't want people only to
vote we want them it implies and
informed we want an informed ballot and
that's one reason why I think it's
really important to focus on college
students because college students are
you know how the education and they have
the resources at their disposal they
have their colleagues they have
libraries they have their professors in
order to really to to inform themselves
in order to vote we should also point
out that the that the sometimes the
barrier to knowledge shouldn't be too
high I just tell my students you know
you know the water and Conservation
Board thing at the end of the ballot you
don't have to vote for them you know and
but I you know you put you I would pull
up a ballot for them because I didn't
want them to be surprised or freaked out
you can at this Secretary of State's
often in Minnesota you can pull the
ballot up here's the ballot here's going
to look like there's a water
conservation board but you know this is
what else you're gonna have to do and
that helps people when they walk in to
do something unfamiliar for some of them
which is voting so you know I'm gonna
end here because I'm be on time but the
I would just say all of us are connected
to the structural problem of voting in
this country and as such we have because
we are socially connected a problem we
have diverse responsibilities to
collaborate with people to help people
exercise their legal right and their
civil responsibility to vote and so this
is our responsible to ourselves our
country our communities and if I may say
to the world okay why because I I have
so many colleagues around the world who
say if only we could vote newest
elections u.s. elections affect us so
much and yet we have no say but the
people who have a say apparently don't
appreciate the you know the importance
of their vote thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so is there some collective so I've done
research on there's 22 countries in the
world have a compulsory voting 14
countries of a duty to vote in their
constitution though there's not complete
overlap between those two groups okay
you know a duty develop the Constitution
but it might you might not have a
compulsory voting and vice versa
Latin American countries are
particularly well represented in both
groups and not surprising they have high
participation rates I guess I actually
think that there's a really strong
libertarian strain in this country and I
think that if you were to start
campaigning for obligatory voting that
you would kind of be about strategic I
think strategically you would just hit
up so much against kind of this
libertarian notion of a of a right to
vote in a right not to vote and you
spend all your time arguing about that
rather than and then I'm getting to the
issue which i think is a civic you know
responsibility to vote but
if you just feel like we shouldn't you
don't think if there was a move to make
[Music]
our voting okay that's the research I
should have done and didn't do but in
general us voting turnout is lower than
most major democracies in the world okay
so we are known we're known for having a
low voter turnout and and it has I think
it has to do more with some of the
complications of our electoral system it
has there's some things I spoke about
you know with this two party
presidential system so we know that
parliamentary systems with proportional
representation often get more people
mobilized to vote right because because
you know a small group that votes for
the Green Party they get over a
threshold let's say they'll get
reputation in Congress where here people
feel like they aren't getting
representative because we have a
presidential system and if single-member
districts where the small and all small
parties are crushed out so I think that
us low voting maybe due to a series of
the nature or political system more than
the necessarily unresponsiveness of
people Phil I appreciate your lecture
your answer now erases the institution
first and I'm wondering why you're being
so shy about it not just mandatory
voting bad disillusionment Witness
system has a lot to do right with
staying at home and Susie as a mom you
know that probably the bump that you
talked about in the youth vote and a lot
to do with Bernie's candidacy no so
how irrational is it actually for the
voter to feel that there are systemic
blockages okay we know that Hillary
Clinton got two and a half million more
votes right then our current president
and yet there is a kind of shyness in
the discourse that we are having about
institutions why
I mean I'm remembering Robert doll's
little book that was part of the castle
section he said how democratic is the
American Constitution mm-hmm I mean I'm
here in the presence of Harold Koh and
others you know it may set me right but
they really are elements built in to our
system of insurance to discourage
increased popular participation we are
not Civic Republican in the sense in
which you know some of the Latin
American models are let's just did some
of the institutional issues right now we
are told that the gerrymandering system
is such that congressional seats the
number of congressional seats that will
swing possibly swing the twenty it is
just very very low so districts are
locked in and that's the case before the
Supreme Court and that's incredibly
important in a democracy right if you
really do feel that nothing that your
vote cannot shift that situation you get
very discouraged a proportional
representation Lani Guinier put this
issue on the docket about 15 years ago
she was chased out of court as if she
was
nobody should have that vote so I guess
my question to you is why not be a bit
more institutionally radical and say
this is a time when we have to ask these
questions because I agree with you that
I think this is the time of the worst
threat to American democracy
I certainly have ever experienced
understand I came to this country in
1917 you know we are about to lose the
Republic so why shouldn't we be why
shouldn't we be over article in our
institutions thank you
well I'm taking this on when it's a
series of lectures about responsibility
okay first and so this is one piece of a
broader set of lectures I'm not
primarily interested in a primarily
skill to talk about but in which I'm
arguing that in all cases structural
institutional matters issues matter and
that people are working on them and that
they're important but somehow we're
always using them as an as I think I
think individuals are using in this way
where we talk about the theories and we
don't have to discuss personal
responsibility and I just feel like the
difficulty of increase of getting
increasing our vote we have such a wide
margin it you know 80% of young people
did not vote in midterms you know that's
that's a huge gap there and the amount
and a lot of those people are you know
forty five percent are you know I think
actually sixty percent are registered so
even without registering a single new
person you could get a dramatic increase
in in in voting in the midterms with no
additional you know change institutions
just getting people to the polls okay
and so I don't of course I think we
should think about these others but I'm
enough of a kind of a realistic
political scientist student of
comparative politics to know guess what
those institutional features are really
really hard to change there are very few
examples and you know if Francis Harris
cream is out very
examples in the world we're mature
modern democracies have complete have
done some major revamping of their
political system okay and it does
usually come after major crises and Wars
but I don't see it it's a very likely
scenario that we're gonna get PR system
that we're gonna get obligatory voting I
I think it's fine to struggle for those
we're gonna get rid of the electoral
college you know we know the barriers to
that'll in stress change are extremely
high and we have one issue at our
disposal that is both I think ethically
the right thing to do I think it's a CLE
the right thing to do to ask people to
step forward take responsibility and
people are saying they're so
disillusioned and here I have to bring
up my Latin learning experience you know
I'm sorry have you ever lived in the
country with outer democracy
do you know what it's like to live in
real authoritarianism you know what it's
like to be afraid to you know that your
friends are being taken away and
tortured and so part some of it it's
it's some of this this disillusionment
is this comparison to these ideals we
have a democracy and it's wonderful for
us to struggle for ideals but the notion
that I'm so disillusioned I can't spend
a half an hour to go to vote what's that
about
so yeah
very low voter turnout in elections and
actually huge possibly impact and if
you'll permit me to tell my one final
story of the day well I came I had
permission to use his name to tell it my
colleague Steve Walt at the Kennedy
School some of you know his wife is
extremely involved in local politics and
there was a local election she was
supporting you know she had strong
people she was supporting for city
council to women city council and she
just told him you know go vote vote for
these people he drove in the driveway
6:30 and he remembered he hadn't voted
so he turned around Brighton was open to
until 7:00 he votes the next thing he
learns that the candidate won counts one
by one vote one vote his boat he thinks
well so of course then the person
insisted on a recount the opponent sits
at a recount they recount and they won
by three votes okay but it there are
local elections where literally these
lectures are being decided by one vote
or three votes so they're exactly the
place where where one can have the most
difference and it's certainly for
families with young children these
school decisions are being made locally
but for all four important environmental
decisions are being made as well and so
it's exactly an example where you you
know it's not at all irrational to vote
if you care about those local issues I
know people have played around with that
once I was telling me about they were
they know there's been some experiments
done with it but you know but you know
incentives backfire there's a
psychological literature where we
actually know that sometimes where you
offer money for something people value
at less and I think it's a dangerous
thing to go the route of paying people
to vote and and it's a because
and so I would not I would not recommend
it I mean we we have incredible really
there's incredible Tobias is in this
country that you have incredible
privileges and rights whatever our
disillusionment you know compared to
citizens in many many parts of the world
with incredible privileges and rights
and to suggest you to have to pay your
citizens to go vote you know and I think
you see different norms about voting
with culture where the institutional
changes that we can make that could be
made that are realistic to make or
changes in voter registration same-day
voter registration yields higher voter
turn all the big high turnout states
with a few exceptions like Massachusetts
all of them have same day voter
registration that's a it's a it's a
reasonable policy it's been adopted by a
lot of states and it is effective with a
lot of so that would be one that I would
highly recommend that people should be
lobbying and you know working on but
it's being you know resisted as you know
for because this this whole you know
feeling that it could lead to fraud even
though there's no evidence that leads to
fraud but I so motor-voter a stuff also
is effective so when people go to get
their drivers license to get them to
it's how them register to vote at that
time it's another very effective and
very costly a low low cost method so
yeah
though among these populations like like
within the states at all the same day
registration they're slipping variants
like have you seen within different
region like yeah so I'm from Minnesota
you hurt my friend Minnesota Minnesota
is that okay so we're Minnesotans right
what do you think about norms in
Minnesota in fact so you know
seventy-four percent that's what
Minnesota has highest in the nation's
always high so nation and yes there's a
civic culture and of a norm to vote and
that you know the average up to yeah
disappear that's very much happening
under Trump's administration so what do
you think are indicators for norm
changing I think it depends on how
people frame things that they frame it
as more disillusionment or most
dangerously as they frame it as a need
for violence then then that could you
know take people you know out of the
voting system but I think and just from
what talking to Yale students last night
I think that there is a it you know on
among some groups of young people and on
some campuses I think there's an
emerging culture that will begin to
place more more emphasis but I mean I
don't even back in Minnesota back
leaders in Minnesota when I told my
colleagues I just told my colleagues I
said voting day is coming near it's the
time we all need to explain to our
students how to vote and they went you
do what like they thought that was like
kind of well that's that's interesting I
never thought of that
you know I'm saying you know there's the
Secretary of State has a great you know
you just go in class you pull up the
Secretary of State's website you say put
in your zip code it tells you where it
tells you the address of where to go to
vote
pull up your ballot you know exactly
what's gonna look like when you walk in
so you can prepare for it you know here
bring your gas bill along because that's
the ID you're gonna need if you don't
have a government issue ID you know and
but that people that was not the norm
among political scientist so it's not
Norman political scientists what's the
norm you know in I don't know in in any
other in any other department if a
political scientist can't so to say this
is part of my you know the universities
have as a mission civic engagement it
should not be considered at all a
partisan act to walk into class and say
today we're going to talk about how to
vote and yet apparently people are not
doing it or seeing that it's
inappropriate in in a college and I
think that hat I just think it has to be
changed okay keep going yeah Harold in
jail again let's go another round
[Music]
all I can say when I did the research on
the history of duties and rights there's
a distinct anglo-american tradition
which is is rights versus rights so this
is the smoking issue right in the end it
was you have red smoke but I have my
right to health is more important and
that trumps your right to smoke right so
the angle of in tradition is very much
this rights versus rights tradition and
and we get we constrain people's rights
by harm they're doing to others right in
that America which is all of these
mandatory voting are all that America
they have a long tradition of what I
call the rights and duties tradition
okay that's it's in their constitution
it came from Spain okay so you don't you
you that that mandatory voting is
something that has a whole history
behind it that we don't have here and so
I I love your ideas that I have opposed
I think it's a
I loved him a voting machine in this
country that I could that people could
walk into and push you know I refuse to
vote I think that would be fabulous but
I just don't think it's gonna happen and
as such I'm recommending you know that
that we do everything possible to
enhance voting the voluntary means and I
think voluntary means are more powerful
and people give them credit for this I
keep giving these examples you know how
do we go from you know these amazing
changes we've seen in this country of
you know from from not you know no one
even knowing what recycling was to a you
know to we in in Massachusetts at least
you know recycling everywhere how do you
know how have we created this norm
change I mean you guys all must have it
to norm changes recycling right you know
you're holding a bottle and you're like
getting the creeps because you're gonna
have to throw it in a trash bin and it's
just making you almost know it doesn't
want us have that reaction I the only
one but you know what I mean uh yeah you
know so so why do we feel that way about
something important but not as important
as voting and we don't don't why is it
that people just don't get a sense of
deep you know anxiety when because they
have been able to vote I don't know yes
comments Harold about you know why do we
dream bigger right because you started
by telling us link these people thought
they were crazy when they were loving
for these moms you know the people that
thought let's get rid of slavery they
didn't think like well this is you know
feasible they thought this is a by crazy
for fighting this and they were fighting
really insurmountable challenges so why
can't we think bigger why can't we think
let's push it and there aren't people
doing it your call
Larry Lessig a Harvard is being like
he's really trying to think like
Hollywood get rid of the electoral
college and people aren't actually so
this is a moment where people are trying
to push bigger but I think that it's
compatible with what you're trying to
say maybe maybe what we need us to first
once everybody gets more used to voting
and that norms been vetted then we can
tackle some institutional and more of
this you know what we actually don't
have a right not to the right and so
maybe we need to you know maybe it's
like like your own cascade theory you
know like we got it in order for the big
cascade to happen you need some build-up
so what's that so you know it's not yeah
I I think that you're both right your
position that this is what may be right
feasible right now but I also don't
think that you should limit yourself by
say I'm like this is all we should be
doing because I think for ethical
political reasons we also should know
that's a terrific point and I just say
it's I do not believe these are mutually
exclusive I totally don't think they're
mutually exclusive okay but I do think
that what I'm saying can you know we can
start this tomorrow they started it
already you know I mean you know Nancy
Thomas and her operation she like said
and tell him anyone wants me to come
down to Yale and talk about our research
and you guys have received the Yale
report from unsolved somewhere it's
there you it has all the information
exactly about what percentage of people
Yale students are voting and and they
can't give it to me but they can give it
to you because that's the deal of how it
works but so they should totally not be
mutually exclusive there so there's
amazing stories in the history of
campaigns of how people start out modest
like my favorite is women's suffrage
women people African women's suffrage
started with the thumb start with the
idea that married women didn't need to
vote for example because hey a married
woman being represented by their
husbands you know and when you look back
you it like what were they thinking of
but but so it there there many proposals
should be moving ahead ok many proposals
and they're not mutually exclusive but
one of those proposals
one of those proposals must be about
dramatically enhancing voting through I
think normative campaigns around the
absolute importance of the right to vote
but I you know can we work for mandatory
voting you know we should definitely try
and Rachel you had another question no I
I just wanted to bring up examples of
the present and they are quite minimal
but they mediate a little bit between
the big picture and what can we do now
one of them is obviously that to the
whole issue of redistricting and I'm
very worried about it because the court
the Supreme Court is sitting on it now
but California and a bunch of other
states have given it to an independent
commission okay so one can one can make
this proposal on a bipartisan basis on
the grounds of fairness equity
transparency etc that's one step the
other is something I wanted to ask you
about apparently a like Kaiser is part
of a movement that is getting trying to
get states to sign on that the candidate
that has been elected in the state will
then become for the majority say that it
will become binding on the electoral
college I'm not expressing this very
well but he's apparently trying to get
the majority can ride with them do you
know about this this proposal which is I
don't know enough about I just know a
little about and that again you know
much more realistic than changing the
electoral college is the idea that
what's not mandated is this notion that
the you know the electors couldn't
divide their votes to reflect the and
their number of states have done it
already
and so it's out it's absolutely possible
that one could campaign more for that
right and the dilemma is that you know
okay the states that will camp you know
well can't only some states will
campaign for it and others won't
and it might in fact disadvantage some
various states that are campaigning for
it so final yes I was wondering if you
had any thoughts about the relationship
between the cooperation and
communication technology and social
media platforms on the likelihood of the
sort of bottom-up norma merchants you
can see it facilitating the type of peer
pressure that you need in order to kind
of give people positive affirmations to
those on the other hand you can see a
sort of countervailing pressure with
social media where people get the
opportunity to kind of perform their
political commitments in a sort of
low-cost way and then get lots of
affirmation makes it right right so I
mean I think you're absolutely right
that social media has sometimes played a
double role right and that is sometimes
they can be used to mobilize and some
kind it can be used to keep privatized
right privatize and give the impression
of activity political activity without
having to do anything aside from play
with your computer your phone right but
there's thousands examples including sad
examples well in in Egypt and elsewhere
where social media was a huge tool for
public mobilizing of individuals and
there's no there's no reason why social
media could not be harnessed to this
campaign you know of of creating new
norms about about responsibility to vote
and like you know young people like
yourself are the ones that are going to
think about how what how would that be
you know how would you do that if you
were really trying to think about how
you would persuade your you know friends
and fellow students to vote I mean the
questions do we even know if people are
voting you know how how will we help or
won't even begin to do that yeah using
social media
there's much more of this last election
cycle that they weren't for much more
okay so the like some things yeah and
you hadn't seen that before the people
being said but telling mentioning that
they voted okay right no I think social
media could be a tool it could be an
important tool for this but I disorder
depends on a on you know they brought
what the campaign is and how they're
doing it no just that I really
appreciate people's comments and
suggestions and I this you know is part
of a book project and so I've been
taking down read your reactions and I
will take them very very much into
account and Bill is here you've been in
my editor for this at Yale and he's here
to hearing what you have to say and so
so thank you thank you for those remarks
and I
[Applause]
[Music]